today's news surrounding Lieutenant
General Flynn had absolutely nothing to
do with President Trump as Greg just
said but that didn't stop the mainstream
media's echo chamber from once again
predicting the downfall of the
administration take a look the thing
that struck me coming from the White
House podium is saying that this has
nothing to do with the president how
could that even come out of a White
House press Secretary's now I think at
the end of the day we're going to see
that general Flynn had a lot of
incriminating information about the
president Trump has always treated him
with kid gloves as opposed to others in
this melodrama
you know Comey Michael Cohen where he's
gone on and called on them but he seems
very concerned about what Michael Flynn
has to say about him
we don't know why Mike Flynn lied we
don't know whether anyone including
President Trump directed him to do it
and if Trump did play a role in this is
that why the president is treating Mike
Flynn with kid gloves the big headline
here is judge finds this behavior
treasonous not just Flynn but all the
people that Quinn coordinated with in
creating these lies it's a bad day for
the narrative that this is just a
witch-hunt and there's nothing serious
there joining us now is the author of
why we fight Fox News national security
strategist Sebastian Gorka or a good
evening dr. Gorka one of the things that
is seems to continuously come back at us
is James Comey lying or have being
inconsistent in terms of his own answers
regarding the same thing so for example
we've got James Comey saying you know
that it had to be a coincidence that
after the tarmac meeting between Bill
Clinton and Loretta Lynch there just
happened to be a meeting between justice
and the FBI but there was never anything
mentioned about this not only that we
know that James Comey after his
classified meeting his briefing with
president-elect Trump he gets into an
FBI vehicle and on an FBI laptop writes
up a memo that is by nature classified
because it's a summary of a meeting with
the president which he gives to his free
his law professor friend too leaked to
the media that is a crime
judge with regards to what happened
today it's very very clear I was on the
transition team with general Flynn I
worked in the White House with general
Flynn the call to the ambassador to the
Russian ambassador was utterly legal
that was Mike Flynn's job the contents
of the conversation were likewise
utterly legal requesting potentially the
Russian ambassador's support in a vote
at the UN to prevent Israel from being
boycotted how is that illegal
but the FBI had the full transcript of
the discussion so why did Jim Comey send
those agents to the White House in for a
flagrant denial of White House Counsel
procedure it was a classic entrapment
ploy well you know not legal entrapment
in the sense that we prosecutors
understand it but what it was was a set
of perjury trial a person without a
doubt okay let's now bring into the
conversation Republican Congressman
darrell Issa all right good evening
congressman the the issue that we just
heard we just heard a bunch of sound off
by the mainstream media and those on the
left
they've got Flint guilty of treason
Flint should be in jail
Flint is is the president Trump's puppet
I mean sometimes I wonder if we're
watching the same news in fact the
prosecutors even said that that's not
appropriate treason in this situation
and yet that the the overreach is
non-stop
well you know what Sebastien Gorka just
said is very important for your viewers
to understand which is anything he may
have done that for which he may have to
pay a price he did none of it was done
if you will
relative to the investigation of any
wrongdoing by the president nothing was
done there yes he failed to register as
a foreign agent yes he lied to the FBI
and whether its entrapment or not
remember that James Comey had one
intention clearly before Donald Trump
was president and afterwards which was
to get to Donald Trump and you can see
it in everything he did he didn't he
didn't keep Flynn from becoming the
National Security Advisor which he
potentially could have done with this
transcript if it was so volatile he
certainly could have told the president
that that Flynn was misleading or lying
to people which could have affected his
being fired sooner and certainly in the
name of national security would have
been the right thing to do James Comey
from day one has been a corrupt cop
trying to get to the president and it is
it shows in everything he's done
including what he failed to do which was
to be honest to both Barack Obama and to
President Trump when he was talking
about what he knew when he knew it and
what should be done in the name of
national security all right and
Sebastian Gorka I mean the whole concept
of the Flynn possibly being a foreign
agent and not registering as one what we
know now that that was not the case when
he was in the White House and yet the
left is suggesting that he was a foreign
agent while he was in the White House
that was made absolutely clear that was
not the case today's proceedings were a
fast first the the fara Act nobody has
gone to jail for hack for writing an
op-ed for a NATO ally which is what
general Flynn did he wrote an op-ed
piece supporting the Turkish government
but we're not at war with Turkey no
matter how much we dislike air Dewan
secondly this totally spurious Logan Act
charge against the prayer against the
the National Security Adviser
if the Logan Act were about a serious
crime John Kerry should be doing 20 to
life right now for his secret
negotiations with Iran after he left
office and when the Trump administration
came into power John where's John
Kerry's arrest why isn't he being woken
up at 2:00 a.m. and put in manacles and
shackles it's absolute absurdity in the
fear congressman Issa you know as we as
we listen to the facts and we're getting
the facts out here the fear is that none
of the the
the illegalities the unethical behavior
on the part of the people on the left
that are they going to ever be made
accountable for they skated during
Obama's eight years and they are skating
through these first two years because of
good old Jeff Sessions IV haven't heard
a word from this guy Huber and you know
Hope Springs a turtle as it relates to
this new guy but what do you think is
gonna happen well I think the insurance
policy that ELISA Paige and Peter struck
talked about has been working for two
years for two years the American people
have been distracted from the real
accomplishments of this president and he
has been forced to both do the work of
the President and to deal with these
endless assaults let's let's face it two
years ago
James Comey did not tell the president
things he should have told her because
he was trying to indict the president it
is now 2 years later and he still
doesn't have a case even with a special
prosecutor of essentially his buddy
Muller yes it is his body Muller indeed
sebastien his buddy Muller is a guy that
you know was his guardian angel during
those famous John Ashcroft Hospital
moments that he remembers vividly but
can't remember 245 times anything that's
happened in the last few months when he
appears before Congress yeah that that's
his example of leadership and being
loyal to the truth the fact is Robert
Muller is in such a conflict of interest
from day one of becoming special counsel
why rod Rosen Stein we have to recall
this rod Rosen Stein made him special
counsel to investigate the president
that day after rod Rosen thought Stein
escorted him to the White House to
interview for the job of FBI director
again Robert Muller crashed and burned
in that interview the president said no
I need new blood you're not going to be
the new director 20 less than 24 hours
later rod Rosenstein makes him the
special counsel to investigate the man
in front of whom he failed to get his
old job back how can he be an impartial
investigator he can't he should never
have accepted that Commission I hear
congressman Isis saying exact
alright thank you so much